Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 11, Lisp. So I started the new job out here in California, and people are so much healthier out here. It's a little depressing, I'm not going to lie. Yeah, you know, I think it's, I'm kind of trying to weigh you down, but it's only a matter of time before you'll be playing Ultimate Frisbee and uh cross-country running and all that stuff
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 11 期，Lisp。我刚在加州开始了新工作，这里的人们健康多了。说实话，这让人有点沮丧。是啊，我知道，我觉得这有点让你感到压力，但你迟早也会开始玩极限飞盘、越野跑之类的运动。
so so the my cube mate the person who works in the cubicle with me has one of these standing desks so oh yeah mine does too so she actually stands up the entire day she i mean she has a chair but i've never i don't think i've ever seen her use it and oh really see the guy who sits next to me he has a weird chair like when he does have to sit or want to sit, his chair is such that he, like, sits on his shins, kind of. What? Yeah, because his desk is high, right? So, he can't use a regular chair. So, he has this weird chair where his knees bend, like, only a little bit. That's weird.
所以，我的隔间邻居，那个和我一起在隔间工作的人，有一个站立式办公桌。哦，是的，我也有。她实际上整天都站着，我是说她有椅子，但我从来没见过她用过。哦，真的吗？你看，坐在我旁边的那个人，他有一把奇怪的椅子，当他不得不坐下或想坐下时，他的椅子让他看起来像是跪坐在小腿上。什么？是啊，因为他的桌子很高，对吧？所以他不能用普通的椅子。于是他有了这把奇怪的椅子，膝盖只能弯曲一点点。那太奇怪了。
It's more of, like, a leaning than a sitting. Like a massage chair or something. I don't know. This sounds weird. Oh man. I don't know how to describe it, but yeah, he stands all day too. It's pretty nuts. Yeah.
与其说是坐着，不如说是靠着。就像按摩椅之类的。我不知道。这听起来很奇怪。天哪。我不知道该怎么形容，但确实，他也整天站着。这太疯狂了。是啊。
So did you get a standing desk? No, I've actually been thinking about it because my desk is kind of low and I'm kind of tall. And so I was like, maybe I should get a standing desk and then like a chair that's just really high, like a, you know, like a bar chair or whatever. And I was thinking that'd be pretty nice because sometimes I would like to stand up and stretch while you know working so i've made a compromise and i got an exercise ball um you know like a big exercise ball and i sit on that and the idea being that you know you can kind of bounce around and you have to keep yourself stable but i'm having to work up to it so like you know the first time i like sat into it kind of too long and my back was killing me so now i had the same thing did you yeah i sat on it i sat
那你买站立式办公桌了吗？没有，我其实一直在考虑，因为我的桌子有点低，而我个子又有点高。所以我当时想，也许我应该买个站立式办公桌，然后再配一把很高的椅子，比如吧台椅之类的。我觉得那样会很不错，因为有时候我想在工作时站起来伸展一下。所以我做了一个折衷，买了一个健身球，你知道，就是那种大健身球，我坐在上面。我的想法是，你可以坐在上面弹来弹去，还得保持平衡，但我还在适应中。第一次坐的时间太长了，背痛得要命。我现在也有同样的情况。是吗？是的，我坐在上面，我坐在
on it and i was like i'm gonna try this out because there's one in our in our cube and uh like after like about halfway through the day around like three or four in the afternoon like my back started really hurting and i couldn't figure out why i was like god i just back pain i understand and i was like wait a minute it's this freaking ball yeah i didn't even last a day so now i'm working my way up so i've slowly been sitting more and more so i think today i sat you know like probably three or four hours on it and uh did okay like i'm not tired or sore or anything i'm trying to so that's one of my things and i i work on the fourth floor so i've been taking the stairs up and down i think i've only ridden the elevator twice the whole time i've been there nice that's really good so that's part of my uh you know try to do better
上面，我想试试看，因为我们的隔间里有一个。大约在下午三四点钟，也就是一天过了一半的时候，我的背开始真的很痛，我搞不清楚为什么。我当时想，天哪，我背痛。我理解。我当时想，等一下，就是这个该死的球。是的，我连一天都没坚持住。所以现在我正在慢慢适应，今天我大概在上面坐了三四个小时，感觉还行，没有感到疲劳或酸痛。我正在尝试，这是我的目标之一。我在四楼工作，所以我一直走楼梯上下。我想我待在那里的整个时间里只坐过两次电梯。不错，那真的很好。所以这也是我“努力做得更好”的一部分。
routine because i'm not playing a super extreme exercise frisbee with you yes so i just uh i found uh you know um at our work they have uh like sort of like a jungle gym for adults that they had just built yeah this is pretty crazy so um they have like that climbing rope did you ever have that when you're in middle school it's just like a huge rope i know what you're talking about yeah yeah you have to kind of use your arms they have one of those but it's it's it's made of like plastic fiber instead of wool and so um it has it gives you like the worst rug burn so i tried it for the first time yeah and i got about halfway up the rope and i gave in and when i when i was coming down my hands they just got all tore up and then all the jocks laughed at you yeah that's right i
日常习惯，因为我不会和你一起玩那种超极限的飞盘运动。是的，所以我发现，在我们的公司，他们建了一个类似成人丛林健身房的地方。是的，这太疯狂了。他们有那种攀爬绳，你在中学时玩过吗？就是那种巨大的绳子。我知道你在说什么。是的，你得用手臂的力量。他们有那种绳子，但它是用塑料纤维做的，而不是羊毛，所以它会让你磨掉一层皮。我第一次尝试时，爬到一半就放弃了。当我下来的时候，我的手被磨破了。然后所有的运动员都嘲笑你。是的，没错，我
got beat up even at work it's sad high school memories all over again um yeah they stuffed me a trash can it wasn't pretty but they have like uh those things that have you seen these they're like platform like tables they look like tables but they're anchored into the ground and you have to sort of jump onto the table but it's really high it's like twice the height of a coffee table they actually have different sizes but the one i was on was like that and so just from standing still you have to jump onto this table and then jump off and then keep going back and forth and they had like a whole bunch of different like they had like a little demo day and i went to it and they had little routines that you should do to get you know more fit and stuff like that but being fit is definitely like huge over here in
甚至在工作中也被欺负，这太悲哀了，全是高中时的回忆。他们把我塞进垃圾桶，那场面可不好看。但他们还有那种东西，你见过吗？它们看起来像桌子，但固定在地上，你得跳到桌子上，但它非常高，大约是咖啡桌高度的两倍。他们其实有不同尺寸的，但我用的那个就是那样。所以你必须从静止状态跳上这张桌子，然后跳下来，反复进行。他们举办了一个演示日，我去了，他们有一些你应该做的日常锻炼来让你变得更健康之类的。但在加州，保持健康绝对是非常重要的。
california yes it is and i'm failing at it so my goal is to improve slightly so i can feel better about myself yeah it's like let's get all the nerds in one place and then try and get teach them to exercise yes they put like a few non-nerd people in just to make the nerds feel bad yeah that's right let me show you how it's really done if you weren't a nerd so well on to programming news yes speaking of exercising let's exercise our processors with uh with running cuda natively on the cpu yeah yeah so um i know you've been you've done this a little and i've done some of this but there's a uh you know the new one of the new things that's come out recently is the programming general purpose programming of graphics processing units so the things that are in your computers pretty much all the computers nowadays to some extent, to run your graphics and accelerate anything with drawing to the screen,
是的，确实如此，而我在这方面做得不好。所以我的目标是稍微改进一下，这样我能对自己感觉好一点。是啊，就像是把所有的书呆子聚在一起，然后试图教他们锻炼。是的，他们放了几个非书呆子进去，只是为了让书呆子们感到难堪。没错，让我来教你如果不是书呆子该怎么做。好了，进入编程新闻。是的，说到锻炼，让我们用在 CPU 上原生运行 CUDA 来锻炼一下我们的处理器吧。是的，我知道你做过一点，我也做过一些。但最近出现的新事物之一是图形处理器的通用编程，也就是你电脑里的那些东西，现在的电脑在某种程度上都有，用来运行图形并加速任何屏幕绘制任务。
with 3D rendering like for games and all that's handled by these GPUs, which basically come down to many core, small, lightweight processing cores that are able to do tons of tasks in parallel for instance when you you know have to figure out where a triangle should show up on the screen there's maybe millions and millions of triangles on us in a given frame of a game and so you can do all of those calculations in parallel and so these graphics processing units have gotten really really good at doing things in parallel. And probably the most... So I don't know.
比如游戏中的 3D 渲染，这些都是由 GPU 处理的。它们基本上归结为许多小型、轻量级的处理核心，能够并行执行大量任务。例如，当你需要计算一个三角形应该出现在屏幕的什么位置时，游戏的一帧中可能有数百万个三角形，所以你可以并行完成所有这些计算。因此，这些图形处理器在并行处理方面已经变得非常非常出色。可能最……我不知道。
So ATI and NVIDIA are the two big graphics processing people. Well, ATI got bought by AMD. Okay. But yeah. So AMD and NVIDIA. And Intel's now starting to do... Well, both of them now are starting to even... Intel and AMD are starting to do interesting things with putting GPUs on the CPUs directly
ATI 和 NVIDIA 是两家大型图形处理厂商。好吧，ATI 被 AMD 收购了。好吧。但确实，AMD 和 NVIDIA。英特尔现在也开始……好吧，他们俩现在甚至开始……英特尔和 AMD 开始做一些有趣的事情，直接把 GPU 放在 CPU 上。
and putting really high bandwidth connections between them. So that's kind of interesting. But NVIDIA has a language that you use to do this general purpose programming for GPUs. And AMD has their own as well. But Nvidia's is called CUDA. And it's a kind of a dialect of C, which is limited. You can't do a lot of the same things you might be able to do in regular C or C++.
并在它们之间建立高带宽连接。这很有趣。但 NVIDIA 有一种语言，你可以用来进行这种 GPU 通用编程。AMD 也有自己的语言。但 Nvidia 的叫 CUDA。它是一种 C 语言的方言，受到了一些限制。你不能做很多在普通 C 或 C++ 中能做的事情。
But for the most part, it's just a C program. And it runs maybe thousands or hundreds of thousands of threads and each one just does a little task so massively parallel and that's really good for certain operations like image processing operations graphics operations certain kinds of like simulations like monte carlo simulations where you you know choose random numbers and you know run a little simulation based on that random number. Things like that can be really good. The problem is that the code between what you write for a CPU
但在大多数情况下，它就是一个 C 程序。它运行着成千上万个线程，每个线程只执行一个小任务，所以它是大规模并行的。这对于某些操作非常有用，比如图像处理操作、图形操作，以及某些类型的模拟，比如蒙特卡洛模拟，即选择随机数并基于该随机数运行小规模模拟。诸如此类的事情效果非常好。问题在于，你为 CPU 编写的代码
and what you write for a GPU are so very different from each other. It can almost make the expense of going through creating a separate code base for your CUDA programs. Unless you're one of these few cases that get you know a thousand x speed up from it it almost makes that not worth it and it's better just to buy or pay more to get the latest and greatest CPU so that you can just have one code base and yeah and the other part of it too is you know the GPU you have to communicate with it it's sort of like an external processor
和你为 GPU 编写的代码非常不同。这几乎使得为你的 CUDA 程序创建单独的代码库变得不划算。除非你是那少数能从中获得千倍加速的情况，否则这几乎不值得，最好还是花更多的钱买最新的 CPU，这样你就可以只维护一个代码库。是的，另一部分是，你必须与 GPU 通信，它有点像外部处理器。
you know whereas the cpu it's right on board and so because of that debugging is much easier on the cpu like you could take a program that's running and just stop it and say all right right now what's the state of the system now let's process one instruction now where are we at but you know because you have this this GPU on a completely different card, the debugging becomes much more difficult. You can't do the kind of cool, hacky things that you can do, that debuggers do for a CPU. Right. Oh, and the other thing is that the pipe between the CPU and GPU, the PCI Express bus, is limited in its speed.
而 CPU 是板载的。因此，在 CPU 上调试要容易得多。比如你可以停止正在运行的程序，说：“好了，现在系统的状态是什么？现在处理一条指令，我们现在在哪里？”但因为你有一个完全在不同卡上的 GPU，调试就变得困难多了。你不能做那些你在 CPU 调试器中可以做的酷炫、黑客式的操作。没错。哦，还有一件事，CPU 和 GPU 之间的通道，即 PCI Express 总线，其速度是有限的。
You think it's really fast, but it's really not all that fast. So there's all this overhead of sending data to the GPU to get processed and getting your results back. And so there's a crossover point where when your data gets big enough and parallel enough, it's worth it to send it there and get it back, it's faster, but below that threshold and get it back it's faster but below that threshold
你以为它很快，但实际上并没有那么快。所以，将数据发送到 GPU 进行处理并取回结果会有很多开销。因此存在一个临界点，当你的数据足够大且并行度足够高时，发送过去并取回是值得的，速度更快。但在该阈值之下，发送过去并取回是值得的，速度更快。但在该阈值之下，
is better to do it on the cpu but if your program has dynamic you know size of data you kind of either have to have code in both and you know choose on your own which one to run or you just got to pick one or the other and suffer you know non-optimal. But what would be ideal is if you could write, for instance, just CUDA code. Well, ideal would be just write C or C++ code and have CUDA automagically do all of this for you. It would be awesome. But short of that, if you could write CUDA code that when you're below a certain size limit, you know the overhead's too much. And so you go ahead and just run that on your cpu or in some case where the gpu isn't available um so for portability reasons to be able to run
最好在 CPU 上完成。但如果你的程序有动态的数据大小，你要么必须在两者中都有代码，要么自己选择运行哪一个，或者你只能选一个，忍受非最优的性能。但理想的情况是，如果你能编写，例如，纯 CUDA 代码。好吧，理想情况是只写 C 或 C++ 代码，让 CUDA 自动为你完成所有这些。那太棒了。但退而求其次，如果你能编写 CUDA 代码，当数据量低于某个限制时，你知道开销太大了，所以你直接在 CPU 上运行它，或者在 GPU 不可用的情况下……为了可移植性，能够运行
the cuda code native on you know just the regular processor the cpu would be a big advantage or when you're doing development you want to yeah run it on the on the cpu once and make sure it works and then run it on the gpu the rest of the works and then run it on the GPU the rest of the time. Yeah, so all those cases are really important cases. And it has not been something that was the first priority because they wanted to get this working right first. But now it looks like some other people are making progress in being able to compile CUDA code down to run on x86
原生 CUDA 代码在常规处理器（CPU）上将是一个巨大的优势。或者在开发时，你想在 CPU 上运行一次以确保它能工作，然后再在 GPU 上运行。是的，所有这些情况都是非常重要的。这并不是第一优先级，因为他们想先确保它能正常工作。但现在看起来其他人正在取得进展，能够将 CUDA 代码编译为在 x86 上运行。
to enable this kind of thing to take place. So it's kind of an interesting article. Hopefully we'll see more of this in the future because it could be a big boon to the widespread use of these GPU processing paradigms. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Yeah, I think it's awesome so uh a lot of people kind of write us and they say oh i really like making video games or i think somebody sent us an email a little while ago and they were using i think visual basic to to write video games and games seem to be it's you masquerading as somebody else oh but they um you know a lot of people get into computers because of games i mean i i love games that's one of the reasons why i got into computers a lot of
以实现这种功能。所以这是一篇很有趣的文章。希望未来能看到更多这样的进展，因为这可能对这些 GPU 处理范式的广泛应用大有裨益。是的，绝对是。是的，我觉得这太棒了。很多人写信给我们说：“哦，我真的很喜欢制作电子游戏。”或者我想不久前有人给我们发了一封电子邮件，他们在使用 Visual Basic 编写电子游戏。游戏似乎是……你伪装成别人。哦，但他们……很多人因为游戏而接触电脑。我是说，我热爱游戏，这也是我接触电脑的原因之一。
my friends have said oh the reason why i got into computer programming is because i want to make wanted to make games and uh you know of course making games is really really hard there's a lot to it and you know often it's done by teams of people. Back in the day, when the games were on Atari and there was 4-bit graphics, one guy would make a whole game. But nowadays, most games are made by teams of hundreds of people. However, there's still a community of people who are just single developers or small teams making games
我的很多朋友都说：“哦，我之所以学习计算机编程，是因为我想制作游戏。”当然，制作游戏真的非常非常难，涉及的内容很多，而且通常是由团队完成的。在过去，当游戏还在雅达利上，只有 4 位图形时，一个人就能制作整个游戏。但现在，大多数游戏是由数百人的团队制作的。然而，仍然有一个由独立开发者或小团队组成的社区在制作游戏。
and and one of the more popular communities is called the roguelike community so a roguelike is is essentially it's a game derived from rogue which is a ASCII game made I think in the 70s but the idea is it's ASCII art so you're a little at sign and uh you move around on the screen and the screen's made up of your little period signs for the floors and for the floor tiles and a little like the little pipe symbol and the minus sign for the walls and things like that and so you know the graphics are simple the gameplay is often quite simple uh sorry sorry the uh mechanic the mechanics and the visualization the gui is simple but the gameplay can become very complex and so people can
其中一个比较受欢迎的社区被称为 Roguelike 社区。Roguelike 本质上是一种源自《Rogue》的游戏，这是一款 ASCII 游戏，我想是在 70 年代制作的。它的理念是 ASCII 艺术，所以你是一个小“@”符号，你在屏幕上移动，屏幕由代表地板和地砖的小句号符号，以及代表墙壁的管道符号和减号组成。所以你知道，图形很简单，游戏玩法通常也很简单……抱歉，抱歉，机制和可视化、GUI 很简单，但游戏玩法可以变得非常复杂。所以人们可以
and it's typically really hard yeah there's often really hard or just you know the games are incredibly complex like dwarf fortress is is one of the more popular roguelikes and you actually you know you manage a civilization and this guy implemented an economy that kicks in. You have a king, and you have to have these nobles that have to be managed. There's an entire water system, which the creator of Minecraft kind of lifted, and so now you can find it in Minecraft. But at the time, Dwarf Fortress was the only game that had that kind of fluid dynamic system. It had the 3D, it has a 3D environment where you can destroy any of the blocks, kind of like Minecraft.
而且通常真的很难。是的，通常真的很难，或者游戏极其复杂。比如《矮人要塞》（Dwarf Fortress）是比较受欢迎的 Roguelike 游戏之一，你实际上是在管理一个文明，这个家伙实现了一个经济系统。你有一个国王，你必须管理这些贵族。有一个完整的水系统，Minecraft 的创造者借鉴了这一点，所以现在你可以在 Minecraft 中找到它。但在当时，《矮人要塞》是唯一拥有那种流体动力系统的游戏。它有 3D 环境，你可以摧毁任何方块，有点像 Minecraft。
So Dwarf Fortress is and continues to be an inspiration for many other games. And Tarn Adams, the creator of Dwarf Fortress, received a ton of notoriety. And I know of several roguelike developers who got job offers from game companies just because of their involvement in roguelikes. So for people who want to make video games, this is a great way to get into it, is to make a roguelike. And for people who want to do that, there is this website, which is How to Write a roguelike in 15 steps at one point it was a while ago but i don't even remember when but at some point i went through this these 15 steps and made a roguelike and yeah and it's it's really rewarding because
所以《矮人要塞》过去是，现在仍然是许多其他游戏的灵感来源。而《矮人要塞》的创造者 Tarn Adams 获得了巨大的名声。我知道有几位 Roguelike 开发者仅仅因为参与 Roguelike 开发就获得了游戏公司的工作机会。所以对于想制作电子游戏的人来说，这是一个很好的切入点，就是制作一个 Roguelike 游戏。对于想这样做的人，有一个网站，叫“15 步教你写 Roguelike”。很久以前，我甚至不记得是什么时候了，我按照这 15 个步骤制作了一个 Roguelike 游戏，这真的很有成就感，因为
at the end you have a finished product and you've also learned a ton um you've learned about when do i create new classes versus when do i make things data driven so for example when i started i had a sword class and then i had a flaming sword class and an ice sword class like they're all dot cpp files uh and i had all this code and no data and i realized you know i don't need all this code all i need is And I realized, you know, I don't need all this code. All I need is just a weapon class, and then I can have a little string which tells me if it's a sword or an axe or whatever. So, I mean, that was a valuable lesson as a programmer is how to make the code data-driven. And, you know, I could go on and on about all the things that I learned
最后你有一个成品，而且你也学到了很多。你学会了什么时候该创建新类，什么时候该数据驱动。例如，当我开始时，我有一个剑类，然后我有一个火焰剑类和一个冰霜剑类，它们都是 .cpp 文件。我写了所有这些代码，却没有数据。我意识到，我不需要所有这些代码。我所需要的只是一个武器类，然后我可以有一个小字符串来告诉我它是剑还是斧头之类的。所以，作为一个程序员，这是一个宝贵的经验，即如何使代码数据驱动。我可以一直说下去，关于我学到的所有东西。
from these 15 steps, but it's really useful. And for anyone, any kids out there who want to start making their own video games, it's a great way to start. Yeah, or adults. Yeah, now you're encouraging me that I feel like I should go do this in addition to sitting on my exercise ball all day.
从这 15 个步骤中，它真的很有用。对于任何想开始制作自己电子游戏的孩子来说，这是一个很好的起点。是的，或者成年人。是的，现在你鼓励了我，我觉得我应该在整天坐在健身球上之外做这件事。
Yeah, maybe you make a roguelike where the character's on an exercise ball. Or he's in an exercise ball, like a giant hamster ball. Oh, yeah. Like maybe if you go forward. Like, if you go to the left too many times, the momentum of the ball keeps moving forward. That could be tough. So, to tie in the steps, it takes you 15 steps to make a roguelike.
也许你可以做一个 Roguelike 游戏，角色坐在健身球上。或者他在健身球里，就像一个巨大的仓鼠球。哦，是的。也许如果你向前走。如果你向左走太多次，球的动量会让你继续向前移动。那可能会很难。所以，把这些步骤联系起来，制作一个 Roguelike 需要 15 个步骤。
But I can have you become a good programmer in just six. Wow, six. They must be pretty tough steps. So the title of this article is actually become a good programmer in six really hard steps. And it's kind of funny because the author of the article actually says that the six steps should take about 10 years or more. Oh, I'm sorry. Actually, I think the first five steps take 10 years and then step six begins at the 10th year and can take possibly forever and it's a little tongue-in-cheek but it's kind of good to go through and it really does in the same line that you're talking about you know learning to program games and teaching you
但我可以在六步之内让你成为一名优秀的程序员。哇，六步。那一定是相当艰难的步骤。所以这篇文章的标题实际上是“六个非常艰难的步骤让你成为一名优秀的程序员”。这很有趣，因为文章的作者实际上说这六个步骤大约需要 10 年或更长时间。哦，抱歉。其实，我想前五个步骤需要 10 年，然后第六步从第 10 年开始，可能需要永远。这有点讽刺，但通读一遍还是很好的。它确实和你刚才说的方向一致，你知道，学习编程游戏并教你
programming because of that this guy just kind of goes through the phases that people tend to go through and therefore if you're trying to go through it or wanting to go through it, understanding what it's going to take to get there and what it involves and kind of how you grow and what kinds first game or doing something that inspires you to want to get into programming to becoming a you know software developer at a company as your job that's a pretty similar path amongst a lot of people they have small variations but it tends to be almost the same for many people and so this guy's defined that pretty well and given some guidance and some help for people who are on that path yeah yeah i read it uh and uh you know i thought it was i thought it was like you said very tongue-in-cheek but is uh a lot of it is really true i mean some of it like writing your own programming language creating your own language
编程。因为这个家伙只是经历了人们倾向于经历的阶段，因此，如果你正在尝试经历它，或者想要经历它，了解达到目标需要什么，它涉及什么，以及你如何成长，从第一个游戏或做一些激励你进入编程的事情，到成为公司里的软件开发人员作为你的工作，这对很多人来说是一条非常相似的路径。他们有小的差异，但对许多人来说往往几乎是一样的。所以这个家伙很好地定义了这一点，并为走在这条路上的人提供了一些指导和帮助。是的，我读了它，我觉得它就像你说的，非常讽刺，但其中很多确实是真的。我是说，有些部分，比如编写你自己的编程语言，创建你自己的语言
really kind of puts things in perspective i mean i feel like i agree that kind of everyone should do that at some point just make some simple language that um you know all it does is let's say it you can uh pass it some new operations like you make a you know plus plus so one plus plus two is is is something else like i don't know maybe it adds two twice i don't know, maybe it adds two twice. I don't know. It doesn't have to be useful, but just the experience of going through and writing a parser and an Alexa and then actually writing the interpreter and things like that is extremely useful.
真的很有视角。我觉得我同意每个人在某个时候都应该这样做，只是制作一些简单的语言，它所做的只是，比如说，你可以传递给它一些新的操作，比如你做一个“++”，所以“1++2”是别的东西。我不知道，也许它加了两次 2。我不知道。它不一定非得有用，但经历编写解析器、词法分析器，然后实际编写解释器之类的过程是非常有用的。
Definitely, definitely. So, yeah, part of becoming a good programmer is being able to sort of work magic. Take things that were meant to be in one environment and bring them to a completely different environment. And Google Native Client kind of does this, where it can take programs that were meant to be on your desktop and bring them to the web. Actually put them inside of a browser. And it's quite amazing how it works. But this news article kind of talks about one specific application where this guy has taken DOSBox, which is a DOS emulator, and ported it to Google Native Client. So what
绝对是。所以，成为一名优秀程序员的一部分是能够施展魔法。把原本属于一个环境的东西带到一个完全不同的环境中。Google Native Client 就做到了这一点，它可以把原本属于桌面的程序带到网络上。实际上把它们放在浏览器里。它的工作方式非常令人惊叹。但这篇新闻文章谈到了一个具体的应用，这个家伙拿到了 DOSBox（一个 DOS 模拟器），并将其移植到了 Google Native Client。所以
you end up with is if you're using a recent enough version of Chrome, you can actually have a DOS operating system in your browser. And he uses this to actually let you play DOS games in the browser. So he's created this MS-DOS file system on his server, I guess. And you can load up different games. So he's got Falcon 3.0 and TIE Fighter and X-Wing. Yeah, he's got all these awesome old school DOS games. And you just literally just go to the website, as long as you're using Chrome, and it's right there. And you just start playing.
最终的结果是，如果你使用足够新版本的 Chrome，你实际上可以在浏览器中拥有一个 DOS 操作系统。他利用这一点让你在浏览器中玩 DOS 游戏。所以他在他的服务器上创建了这个 MS-DOS 文件系统，我想。你可以加载不同的游戏。所以他有《猎鹰 3.0》、《钛战机》和《X 翼战机》。是的，他有所有这些超棒的老派 DOS 游戏。你只需要去那个网站，只要你使用 Chrome，它就在那里。你就可以开始玩了。
It's pretty amazing. And it really kind of showcases the power of Google Native Client. I want to do this right now since i'm in chrome yeah it's totally awesome i played a little bit of tie fighter uh you know to be to be to not get in trouble or anything like that he only has the demo i don't even know how he got his hands on the demo of tie fighter um he must have just had it from way back but um so you only can play the first level but it's still pretty amazing and i think you know as part of the port i mean you should be able to just run anything you want like i don't
这太令人惊叹了。它确实展示了 Google Native Client 的强大功能。我现在就想做这个，因为我正在用 Chrome。是的，这太棒了。我玩了一点《钛战机》，为了不惹麻烦，他只有演示版。我甚至不知道他是怎么弄到《钛战机》演示版的，他一定是以前就有的。所以你只能玩第一关，但这仍然非常令人惊叹。而且我认为，作为移植的一部分，你应该能够运行任何你想要的东西。我不知道细节，但它是一个完整的 DOS 操作系统，所以如果你有自己的《钛战机》，你应该能够把它带到桌面上。但无论如何，它真的很酷。听起来棒极了。你们应该去看看。是时候了吗？我想是“双周工具”的时间了。好的。你有什么？让我猜猜。等等。
know the details but it's a complete dos operating system so if you have your own tie fighter you should be able to bring it to the table i think but either way it's really freaking cool. It sounds awesome. And yeah, you guys should check it out. Is it that time? I think it's time for Tool of the Bi-Week. All right. What do you got? Let me guess. Hang on.
它和我们刚才谈论的内容有关吗？没有。其实是 Google Native Client。真是个反转。是的，所以我的“双周工具”其实是 Google Native Client。真是个反转。是的，我的“双周工具”是 Google Native Client。我一直在摆弄这个。你们有些人可能知道，我在 MAME 上做了很多工作。我是 MAME Hub 的创造者，对于那些不知道的人，MAME 是一个缩写，代表“多重街机模拟器”。但现在它已经发展到涵盖了几乎所有制造过的街机
Is it related to what we just talked about? It's no. It's actually Google Native Client. What a twist. Yeah. So my Tool of the Bi-Week actually Google Native Client. What a twist. Yeah, so my tool of the bye week is Google Native Client. I've been messing around with this. And some of you might know I do a lot of work on MAME. I'm the creator of MAME Hub, which is, well, for people who don't know, MAME is an acronym, and it stands for Multiple Arcade Machine Emulator. But now it's grown to cover almost every arcade machine ever made
以及许多现代游戏机，或者不是现代，许多复古游戏机，比如 NES、SNES 等等。所以这就像是统治一切的模拟器。我一直在 MAME 上进行大量开发，我是 MAME Hub 的创造者，它让你可以在线玩 MAME 游戏。所以你可以和英国的人在线玩《超级马里奥兄弟》。你合法拥有它。没错，只要你在家里合法拥有卡带。
and many modern consoles, or not modern, many retro consoles, like NES, SNES, and all that. So this is sort of like the one emulator to rule them all. I've been doing a lot of development on MAME, and I'm the creator of MAME Hub, which lets you play MAME games online. So you could play Super Mario Bros. online with someone in England. You legally own it. That's right, as long as you legally own the cartridge in your house.
如果你愿意，如果你在湾区，你可以从我这里借一个。我想我还在某处保留着我所有的任天堂游戏。总之，我一直在使用 Native Client，我一直在把 MAME 移植到它上面之类的。我真的很喜欢它，我只是在创建一些示例应用程序，我真的可以看到这个工具链有巨大的潜力。这太令人惊叹了。
And if you want, if you're in the Bay Area, you can borrow one from me. I think I still have all my Nintendo games somewhere. Anyway, so I've been using Native Client for, you know, I've been porting MAME to it and things like that. I've been really into it, and it's just, you know, creating some sample apps, and then I can really see there's tremendous potential in this tool chain. It's just amazing.
我是说，想象一下你拿走你在高中或大学时写的东西，或者也许是一个你非常喜欢的开源应用程序。只要你能用这个 Native Client 编译它，它就能在浏览器中运行。我是说，它是一个网站。所以你可以进行更改，任何访问你网站的人都会自动获得最新版本。你再也不用担心部署之类的事情了。它让你做很酷的事情，比如立即让人们登录。它在你的代码周围有一个 JavaScript 包装器。所以你可以做很酷的事情，比如向某个 Web 服务器发出 AJAX 请求。
I mean, imagine you take something that you wrote, maybe in high school or in college, or maybe it's an open source app that you really like. And, you know, as long as you can get it to compile in using this native client, it runs in the browser. I mean, it's a website. And so you can, you know, make changes and, you know, anyone who visits your website automatically gets the latest version. You don't have to worry about deployment or anything like that anymore. It lets you do awesome stuff like immediately get people signed in. It has a JavaScript wrapper around your code. So you can do cool things like make AJAX requests to some web server.
所以你可以做所有很酷的 Web 事情，比如利用不同的 Web 服务，比如天气之类的。并非常容易地将所有这些与你的桌面应用程序联系起来。所以它很棒。它越来越受欢迎。就像我在新闻部分提到的，有一些非常酷的演示。是的，我是它的忠实粉丝。所以我喜欢看看人们用它做出什么酷的东西。非常酷。
And so you could do all the cool web things like, you know, tap into different web services like the weather and things like that. And tie all that into your desktop application really easily. So it's awesome. It's getting more and more popular. Like I mentioned in the news section, there's some really cool demos. And, yeah, I'm a big fan. So I like to see what kind of cool stuff people make with it. Very cool.
Patrick，你的“双周工具”是什么？我的“双周工具”是 Handbrake，这是一个开源转码应用程序。它适用于 Mac、Windows，我想 Linux 也可以。但重点是，它最初是为 Mac OS 开发的，然后他们也推出了 Linux 版本。但重点是，它最初是为 Mac OS 开发的，然后他们也推出了其他版本。它允许你做的是，非常容易地将你有权使用的视频进行转码
Patrick, what's your tool of the bye week? My tool of the bye week is Handbrake, which is an open-source transcoding application. It's available for Mac, Windows, and I think Linux as well. But the big one is originally it was for the Mac OS, and then they've come out with versions for the Linux as well. But the big one is originally it was for the Mac OS and then they've come out with versions for the others as well. And what this allows you to do is it's really easy for putting videos that you have permission to on your transcoding them
这样它们就可以在你的 iPhone、iPad、Android 设备上播放。哦，有趣。所以你可以拿一张 DVD，比如你的婚礼 DVD 之类的，然后把它移植到你的手机上？是的。所以如果你有一张婚礼 DVD，想在平板电脑上观看，你就会用它来转换，因为平板电脑和手机，虽然它们通常会播放不同的视频，比如许多不同种类的视频，
so that they will play on your iPhone, iPad, Android device. Oh, interesting. So you can take a DVD, like you can take your wedding DVD or something and port it to your phone? Yeah, yeah. So if you had a DVD of your wedding and you wanted to watch that on your tablet, then you would use this to convert it because the tablets and phones, although they will often play different videos, like many different kinds of videos,
它们通常针对特定的分辨率进行了优化，你知道，屏幕尺寸，以及针对一组特定的编码参数，因为它们有硬件加速来执行，例如，H.264 解码。所以如果你把它转换成那种格式，它的性能会好得多，或者如果格式不对，可能根本无法播放。Handbrake 的好处在于它内置了所有这些预设，所以你可以直接说“我想把这个文件编码为 iPod Touch 3G 或第三代”，它就会那样做，或者 iPhone 4，它会知道，或者我想为 iPad 编码，它会继续选择正确的宽度或高度
they're typically optimized for a certain resolution, you know, the screen size, and then also for a certain set of encoding parameters because of the fact that, you know, they have hardware acceleration to do, for instance, H.264 decoding. So if you put it in that format format it's going to perform a lot better or maybe not perform at all if it's not right and what the nice thing about handbrake is is that it has all of those presets in there so you can just say i want this file encoded as for an ipod touch 3g or third gen and so it'll do that or an iPhone 4 and it'll know I did or I want it for an iPad and it'll go ahead and and choose the right width or height
比例，以及使用什么编码参数，使用什么比特率。每当你打开一个视频编码工具，心想“我甚至不知道这里该选什么，能给我一个自动按钮吗”，它就为你提供了。所以你可以直接说你想为哪个设备编码，它就会内置好预设。哦，那太棒了，那是一个非常棒的工具，我以前从没见过这个工具。哦，不，我一定会用它的。是的，它支持广泛的输入，所以它非常不错。它就是那种几乎总是能用的工具，这很好。
then ratio for you and also what encoding parameters to use what bit rates to use those things that whenever you open up a video encoding thing and go I don't even know what to choose here can I please get some like auto button it kind of has for you and so you can just say what device you want to encode for and it'll just kind of uh already have the presets in there oh that's really awesome that is a fantastic tool i've never seen this tool before oh no i'm definitely gonna use it yeah and it has it supports a wide range of inputs um so it's pretty nice it's just one of those things where it almost always works, and that's nice.
拥有一个不需要你准备 15 种不同东西就能完成一项任务的工具真好。是的，而且你知道，既然你把开源工具作为你的“双周工具”，这确实开创了一个先例。是的，这是我一段时间以来的第一次，过去几期我一直在用闭源工具。是的，我又回到了尝试使用开源工具，不仅仅是免费的。不过我们还没做过任何付费工具。所以，我想你是对的，我们从来没做过付费工具。那是因为没有好用的付费工具。我不会那么说。你可以那么说，先生，我不会那么说。有些人想要为他们的应用程序收费，通常有很好的理由，他们完全有权尝试。好吧，够了，哲学时间结束，进入
It's nice to have a tool where it's not like you've got to have 15 different things to be able to do one task. Yeah, and you know, this really sort of sets a precedent now that you've used an open source tool as your tool of the bye week. Yeah, this is the first time in a while I've been doing closed source tools for the last uh few episodes and uh yeah i'm back on the try to do open source not just free we haven't done any paid tools yet though so yeah i don't think so i think i think you're right we've never done a paid tool that's because there's no paid tools that are any good i won't say that you may say that sir i won't say that there are certain people who want to charge for their applications often have very good reasons for doing so and they are more than entitled to try that fair enough so okay enough philosophy time for the
我们本周编程语言的讨论：Lisp。没错。Lisp 是我们要讨论的语言。它非常有趣。如果你对计算机科学和理解历史，以及那些不那么亲力亲为、更像是空中楼阁的理论之类的东西感兴趣，这绝对是一门值得了解的语言。它实际上是在
discussion of our programming language of the week lisp that. That's right. Lisp is the language we're going to be talking about. It's really interesting. It's definitely, if you're into computer science and sort of the understanding, like, the history and sort of the more, I guess, the less hands-on, the more kind of pie-in-the-sky theory and things like that, this is a good language to know. It was actually invented
实现之前就被发明出来了。所以有人……我们有那个人的名字吗？让我看看，John McCarthy，早在 1958 年。所以这是一门非常古老的语言。他形式化了 Lisp 的这个想法，以及构成 Lisp 语言的核心函数，并在甚至还没有实现之前就证明了 Lisp 是图灵完备的之类的。我是说，这一切都是在纸上完成的。这是一个思想实验，对吧？直到很久以后，实际上，我想是几年后，Steve Russell 才创建了第一个 Lisp 实现。所以，是的，Lisp 有着悠久的历史。因为 Lisp 与计算机科学联系如此紧密，所以有大量的 Lisp 方言。
before it was implemented so someone and do we have the person's name let me see john mccarthy uh back in 1958 so this was a very old language he um he kind of formalized this idea of lisp and sort of the the core functions um that constitute the Lisp language and sort of prove that Lisp is Turing complete and things like that before there was even an implementation. I mean this was just all done in paper. It was a thought experiment, right? It wasn't until much later, actually, I guess a few years later, that Steve Russell created the first Lisp implementation. So, yeah, so Lisp has a wide history. Because Lisp is so tied to computer science, there's just tons of different dialects of Lisp.
你知道，有 Scheme 之类的。它似乎是……怎么说呢，它是最广为人知但使用最少的编程语言。人们使用它，但不是每天都用。人们不在日常工作中使用它，但似乎每个学习计算机科学的人都会学习它，甚至只是对计算机编程感兴趣的人也会接触它，他们至少会玩一下。如果不是成为专家，至少也会了解它，但之后就不会再用了。是的，没错。而且我认为，Lisp 的部分问题，我们会在弱点部分讨论更多，但它太碎片化了。我是说，这与其说是 Lisp 的问题，不如说是社会事件的结果。但 Lisp 太碎片化了，有许多不同的 Lisp 编译器或解释器。而且
You know, there's scheme and things like that it seems to be probably the how do you say it's like the most well-known least used programming language like people use it but not every day like people don't use in their everyday jobs but it seems like everybody who goes through computer science learns it or even people who are just interested in computer programming will pick it up and they'll at least play with it. If not learn to be experts in it, you know, at least know it, but then not use it. Yeah, that's right. Yeah. And I think, you know, part of the problems with Lisp and we'll talk about this more in the weaknesses, but is that it's just it's so fragmented right i mean this isn't really a problem with lisp as much as just the just i guess the social sort of just the events that transpired but lisp is so fragmented there's many different compilers for lisp or interpreters i should say and uh you know there's
有太多不同的方言，而且很长一段时间里，没有任何解释器是开源的。所以，每一个都有自己的细微差别，我觉得这真的困扰了 Lisp。但对 Lisp 至关重要的两件事是 car 和 cdr。car 和 cdr 的工作方式是，把 Lisp 中的一切都想象成一对。这一对实际上被称为 cons，C-O-S。所以你有一对对象，但对象本身可以是任何东西。要从一对中获取特定的元素，比如第一个和第二个，你会调用 car 来获取第一个，或者调用 cdr 来获取第二个。所以仅仅有了 cons、car
so many different dialects and for a long time none of the interpreters were open source so um you know each one sort of had its own nuances and and so this is i feel like this is really kind of plagued lisp but um the two things that are sort of critical to lisp are um car and cooter so car and cdr and the way this works is uh think of everything in Lisp as being a pair. And the pair is actually called cons, C-O-N-S. So you have a pair of objects, but the objects themselves, they could be anything. And to go from a pair to the specific elements in the pair, like the first and the second, you would call car to get at the first, or you'd call cooter to get at the second. And so just with cons, char,
和 cdr，就构成了整个 Lisp 语言的基础。它很大程度上基于 lambda 演算，这涉及到一些相当深奥的东西。基本上，lambda 演算是一种形式主义。我们谈论过一阶谓词演算。我们谈论过 Prolog，这只是表示数字和对这些数字进行计算的另一种方式。你可以在维基百科上阅读更多相关内容，但要理解，类似于 Prolog，Lisp 在某种程度上是基于
and cooter, that forms the basis for the entire Lisp language. A lot of it's based on lambda calculus, which gets into some pretty heavy stuff. Basically, lambda calculus is sort of a formalism. We talked about first-order predicate calculus. We're talking about Prolog and this is just another way of sort of representing numbers and the computations on those numbers and you can read about it more Wikipedia but but understand that similar to Prolog Lisp is sort of based on
演算的。所以你可以想象，它不是那种你会用来编写设备驱动程序的语言，对吧？所以这是非常理论化的东西。然而，曾经有过 Lisp 机器。你听说过这个吗？是的。好吧，我想那是在我那个时代之前，尽管也许我当时还相当……
on calculus. And so because of that, you can imagine it's not something you're going to write device drivers for, right? So this is something that's kind of very theoretical. However, there have been Lisp machines. Have you heard anything about this? Yeah. Well, it was a little bit before my time, I guess, although maybe I was still quite
关于微积分。正因如此，你可以想象它并不是那种你会用来编写设备驱动程序的语言，对吧？所以这东西在某种程度上是非常理论化的。不过，确实存在过 Lisp 机器。你听说过这个吗？嗯，我想那是在我那个时代之前一点点，尽管也许我当时还相当
young when some of it was going on. But the Lisp machines was kind of an effort when the personal computers were first coming out to have a machine that was for individual users, which although didn't directly implement Lisp, so there weren't assembly level commands that said, you know, the parts of the lisp language directly what it did was provide a really simple stack-based processor as opposed to a register-based processor which is gets pretty in-depth and probably outside the scope for this discussion but instead of register-based it was stack-based and the commands themselves were meant to be very easily derived by LISP code. So LISP code would translate into very few instructions, as opposed to on a normal register-based CPU, for instance. A single LISP command may take many, many machine instructions to implement and so these this processor architecture was put together in something called a list machine that was
当时其中一些事情发生时我还很年轻。但 Lisp 机器在个人电脑刚出现时算是一种尝试，旨在拥有一台面向个人用户的机器。虽然它没有直接实现 Lisp，所以没有汇编级别的指令直接对应 Lisp 语言的各个部分，但它所做的是提供了一个非常简单的基于栈的处理器，而不是基于寄存器的处理器。这涉及得比较深，可能超出了本次讨论的范围，但它不是基于寄存器的，而是基于栈的，指令本身旨在很容易地由 LISP 代码导出。因此，与普通的基于寄存器的 CPU 相比，LISP 代码可以转换为非常少的指令。例如，一个 LISP 命令可能需要许多许多机器指令来实现，所以这种处理器架构被组合在一种叫做 Lisp 机器的东西中，它
meant to be easily programmed and efficient at writing and using and running lisp programs right so I mean you know I think about the difference between say C and lisp so in C C, just from a data perspective, in C you're dealing with arrays and pointers that point to different spots of memory. And so you do pointer arithmetic. So, for example, if you have an array and you want to loop through the array, you would have a pointer at the beginning of the array and then you sort of increment it's very numerical you just say I want to push my pointer a little bit further and read the data over here and then push it further kind of like you'd read off a tape or a record or something like that
旨在易于编程，并且在编写、使用和运行 Lisp 程序方面非常高效。所以，我的意思是，你知道，我思考过 C 和 Lisp 之间的区别，比如在 C 语言中，仅从数据角度来看，在 C 中你处理的是数组和指向内存不同位置的指针。所以你进行指针运算。例如，如果你有一个数组，并且想要遍历该数组，你会在数组开头有一个指针，然后你对其进行递增，这非常数值化，你只是说我想把指针再推远一点，读取这里的数据，然后再推远一点，有点像你从磁带或唱片之类的东西上读取数据一样。
in lisp you don't have arrays what you have are as I mentioned these pairs yeah so you have pairs so if you want to have say a list if you want to have an array let's say in lisp then what you would have is you'd have a pair the left the first element in the pair would have some item in your list let's say it's a list of numbers so the first element in your pair would have the number say four and the second element of your pair would have a pair in it and then that pair the first element would have a number let's say two and the second element would have another pair
在 Lisp 中，你没有数组，正如我提到的，你拥有的是这些对（pairs）。是的，所以你有对。如果你想拥有，比如说一个列表，如果你想在 Lisp 中拥有一个数组，那么你所拥有的就是一个对。这个对中的左侧，即第一个元素，会包含你列表中的某个项目。假设它是一个数字列表，那么你对中的第一个元素会包含数字，比如 4，而你对中的第二个元素会包含一个对，然后那个对的第一个元素会包含一个数字，比如 2，第二个元素会包含另一个对。
so you see everything is done in pairs and any of the out the two elements in the pair can be either an atom which is you know a number or a word or you word or something that's immutable, something that can't change, like a constant. Or it's either a constant or it's another pair or it's nil. Those are the only three things that can exist. So as we mentioned in JavaScript where there was only four things, in JavaScript there's nil, array, object, and literal. In Lisp, there's only atom, which is the same as literal, pair, and nil. There's only three. So you would think that because it's so simple that, oh, you must be really low level.
所以你看，一切都是以对的形式完成的，对中的两个元素中的任何一个都可以是一个原子（atom），也就是一个数字、一个单词，或者你说的某种不可变的东西，某种不能改变的东西，比如常量。它要么是一个常量，要么是另一个对，要么是 nil。这是仅有的三种可以存在的东西。所以正如我们在 JavaScript 中提到的，那里只有四种东西，在 JavaScript 中有 nil、数组、对象和字面量。在 Lisp 中，只有原子（这与字面量相同）、对和 nil。只有三种。所以你可能会认为，因为它如此简单，哦，它一定是非常底层的。
You must use this for drivers because it's such a simple language. But actually making the language very simple is really what gives it the power and gives it the ability to represent incredibly complex things. And we'll talk about this a little more when we get to the strengths. But understand that, you know, a machine, a regular machine that just has a bank of memory where you can just do malloc and get arrays, that kind of machine doesn't run Lisp very efficiently, especially 30 years ago, 40 years ago. So the idea of the Lisp machine was let's make a machine
你一定得用它来写驱动程序，因为它是一种如此简单的语言。但实际上，使语言变得非常简单正是赋予它力量并使其能够表示极其复杂事物的原因。当我们谈到它的优势时，我们会再多谈谈这一点。但要明白，你知道，一台机器，一台普通的机器，只拥有一块内存，你可以直接进行 malloc 并获取数组，那种机器运行 Lisp 的效率并不高，特别是在 30 年前、40 年前。所以 Lisp 机器的想法是，让我们制造一台
with the constraints of Lisp in mind. Let's make a machine that deals with things in terms of pairs. Right. And I mean, it seems like they were fairly successful at doing that. It was just of lisp in mind let's make a machine that deals with things in terms of pairs right and i i i mean it seems like they were fairly successful at doing that it was just that the competition in the market was somewhere else it was in the traditional register based machines running c and yeah so it seems like there have been many of these instances in the even short-lived software world where even if something made sense or was technically superior, something else won out because of just market inertia or happenstance or various other things. And the Lisp machine kind of fits in that category.
考虑到 Lisp 约束的机器。让我们制造一台以对的形式处理事物的机器。对。我的意思是，看起来他们在做这件事上相当成功。只是市场上的竞争在别处，即在运行 C 的传统基于寄存器的机器上。是的，所以看起来在即使是短命的软件世界中，也发生过许多这样的例子，即使某样东西有意义或在技术上更优越，由于市场惯性或偶然性或其他各种原因，其他东西最终胜出了。而 Lisp 机器有点属于那一类。
Yeah, I'd like to think that being an AI person and being sympathetic to Lisp, I like to think that it's sort of the grandfather of many other languages. Other languages like Python, JavaScript, which is based on... JavaScript was based on Scheme, right? It was inspired by Scheme.
是的，我喜欢认为，作为一个 AI 人士并且对 Lisp 有好感，我喜欢认为它是许多其他语言的祖父。其他语言，比如 Python、JavaScript，它是基于……JavaScript 是基于 Scheme 的，对吧？它是受 Scheme 启发的。
Yeah, and Scheme is a dialect of lisp so there you go and and you know even matlab which is now very popular uh you know you know lisp is sort of the grandfather of all interpreted languages and is is a good source of sort of inspiration for for languages that came after and offered you know much uh more uh boosts and productivity, you know, without all the hindrances that Lisp has. Yeah. Yeah. So, yes, as we mentioned, it has many dialects. But one of the reasons why there's so many dialects is because it's really easy to write
是的，Scheme 是 Lisp 的一种方言，所以就是这样。而且你知道，即使是现在非常流行的 Matlab，你知道，Lisp 可以说是所有解释型语言的祖父，是后来出现的语言的良好灵感来源，这些语言提供了，你知道，更多，呃，更多的生产力提升，你知道，而没有 Lisp 所具有的所有阻碍。是的。是的。所以，正如我们提到的，它有很多方言。但之所以有这么多方言，原因之一是因为编写
an interpreter or a compiler for Lisp. In fact, as we mentioned with the, you know, become a good programmer in six really hard steps, the author even mentions that, hey, you should write a Lisp interpreter as your language, you know, because it's a good start. Yeah, there's so few things you actually, well, I mean, it seems tricky. At the start, it seems so easy to get started because there's so few things you have to implement.
Lisp 的解释器或编译器真的很容易。事实上，正如我们提到的“通过六个非常困难的步骤成为一名优秀的程序员”中所说，作者甚至提到，嘿，你应该编写一个 Lisp 解释器作为你的语言，你知道，因为这是一个很好的开始。是的，实际上你需要做的东西很少，嗯，我的意思是，这看起来很棘手。起初，开始时似乎很容易，因为你需要实现的东西很少。
Yeah, and keep in mind that, and this is true for all languages. I don't know if we've mentioned this before, but most languages are written in themselves. So we have talked about this where, you know, we talked about Python being batteries included where there's a huge corpus of of tools that you have that are available to you when you start programming the vast majority of those tools are written in python this is true even of you know c and lisp and other languages just to a lesser extent so you know 99 of lisp is written in lisp. And, you know, if you could take, like, the common Lisp libraries and, you know, use your own interpreter, you could really have your own Lisp, like, fully featured interpreter in a day. I mean, of course, it wouldn't be fast.
是的，请记住，这对所有语言都是如此。我不知道我们之前是否提到过这一点，但大多数语言都是用它们自身编写的。所以我们谈到过这一点，你知道，我们谈到 Python 是“内置电池”的，当你开始编程时，你有大量的工具可用，绝大多数这些工具都是用 Python 编写的。即使是 C 和 Lisp 以及其他语言也是如此，只是程度较轻。所以，你知道，99% 的 Lisp 是用 Lisp 编写的。而且，你知道，如果你能拿走，比如，通用 Lisp 库，并且，你知道，使用你自己的解释器，你真的可以在一天之内拥有你自己的 Lisp，那种功能齐全的解释器。我的意思是，当然，它不会很快。
It would be nothing like C Lisp. But, you know, it still would be fun. You know, it's a toy to play with. And it seems like the other thing is that there are a lot of people who take Lisp and use it as kind of an intermediate language where you write something in Lisp and then you compile it. We talked about people doing this to JavaScript before,
它完全不像 C Lisp。但是，你知道，它仍然会很有趣。你知道，它是一个可以玩的玩具。而且看起来另一件事是，有很多人把 Lisp 当作一种中间语言，你在 Lisp 中编写一些东西，然后编译它。我们之前谈到过人们对 JavaScript 做这种事，
but people kind of use Lisp as an input language to the compiler, I guess, and then compile it to some other form of a language so um there's closure which is c l o j u r e as opposed to we talked a little bit about the closure kit tools uh last week or last episode um and that is uh implementing lisp on top of java so using the java virtual machine and using lisp as kind of i guess what is at the front end to it and saying yeah nice how do we how do we do that and it's it's got a lot of popularity um and there's also the everybody kind of has their own little
但人们有点把 Lisp 用作编译器的输入语言，我想，然后将其编译成某种其他形式的语言。所以，嗯，有 Clojure，即 C L O J U R E，而不是我们上周或上一集谈到的 Closure Kit 工具，嗯，那是，呃，在 Java 之上实现 Lisp，所以使用 Java 虚拟机，并把 Lisp 用作，我想，前端，并说，是的，不错，我们怎么做呢？它非常受欢迎，嗯，而且每个人也都有自己的小
ways about some of the finer nuances of the language. And so each of those tends to kind of get its own spin out dialect, which initially starts out really close to the one it started from, but then slowly drifts away over time. Yep. Yeah, so some of the strengths of Lisp. One of the strengths is that it has very, very efficient hash tables. And this is tied directly to the fact that there's so few data types. You know, it does a lot of sort of like clever tricks with the pairs.
关于语言一些细微差别的方式。因此，每一个往往都会衍生出自己的方言，最初它与它所源自的那个非常接近，但随后随着时间的推移慢慢漂移开来。是的。是的，所以 Lisp 的一些优势。其中一个优势是它拥有非常、非常高效的哈希表。这直接与它只有很少的数据类型这一事实有关。你知道，它对这些对做了很多类似巧妙的技巧。
And it can actually store a ton of data in a hash table very efficiently by sort of reusing the same data. Lisp is amazing at this. We should explain what a hash table is. Oh, yeah. You've probably never done that. So, yeah. So, a hash table is something that essentially maps one data type to another. One value?
而且它实际上可以通过重用相同的数据，非常高效地在哈希表中存储大量数据。Lisp 在这方面非常了不起。我们应该解释一下什么是哈希表。哦，是的。你可能从来没做过那个。所以，是的。所以，哈希表本质上是将一种数据类型映射到另一种数据类型的某种东西。一个值？
Yeah, I guess one value. Maybe that's a better way of saying it. Essentially maps one value to another. So, for example, let's say you wanted to store the days of the week. So if you put in zero, you got Monday. If you put in one, you got Tuesday, right? So in C, you could just have an array. And at the array index zero, you would just hold the string,
是的，我想是一个值。也许这是更好的说法。本质上是将一个值映射到另一个值。所以，例如，假设你想存储一周中的几天。如果你输入 0，你得到星期一。如果你输入 1，你得到星期二，对吧？所以在 C 语言中，你可以直接用一个数组。在数组索引 0 处，你只需存放字符串，
a pointer to the string Monday. And one, you'd hold Tuesday, so on and so forth. And you'd say, you know, days, open bracket, you know, two to get Wednesday, right? What if you wanted to go backwards? Like what if someone gave you the string and you wanted to return what day of the week it was in numbers So if someone gave you Monday you wanted to return zero So in this case you'd have to use you'd have to use essentially a map and the map would have to map strings to numbers See an array you can think of an array as a map which maps numbers to something else whatever is in the array
一个指向字符串“Monday”的指针。而在 1 处，你存放“Tuesday”，以此类推。你会说，你知道，days[2] 来获取星期三，对吧？如果你想反过来呢？比如如果有人给你字符串，而你想返回它是星期几的数字？所以如果有人给你“Monday”，你想返回 0。在这种情况下，你必须使用，你必须本质上使用一个映射，并且该映射必须将字符串映射到数字。看，数组你可以认为是一个映射，它将数字映射到其他东西，无论数组中有什么。
But whenever you need a map Something that isn't the number let's say you need a map You know a floating point number or as I mentioned a string or maybe you need a map a chess board like the entire board like a whole class with the pieces and where they are. You need to map that to a number. To do something like that, you have to use a map. And one very common map, implementation of a map, is a hash table. What a hash table does is it takes, it basically is based on the principle that you don't actually need the key so in other words I don't actually need to store the string Monday
但是每当你需要一个映射，某种不是数字的东西，假设你需要一个映射，你知道，一个浮点数，或者正如我提到的，一个字符串，或者也许你需要一个映射，一个棋盘，就像整个棋盘，就像一个带有棋子及其位置的完整类。你需要将其映射到一个数字。要做到这一点，你必须使用一个映射。而一种非常常见的映射，映射的实现，就是哈希表。哈希表所做的是它采用，它基本上基于这样一个原则：你实际上不需要键。所以换句话说，我实际上不需要存储字符串“Monday”
in this table you know what what I need is when I get the string Monday I need to know to return zero but it doesn't necessarily mean that I need to hold Monday in the table so that sounds a little confusing, but take, for example, let's say that your hash table, instead of storing the whole string, it just stored the first two letters. So that would be sufficient, right? If someone passed in Monday, then I would just take the first two letters, MO, and just look for that in the table.
在这个表中。你知道，我需要的是当我得到字符串“Monday”时，我需要知道返回 0。但这并不一定意味着我需要在表中保存“Monday”。所以这听起来有点令人困惑，但举个例子，假设你的哈希表不是存储整个字符串，它只存储前两个字母。那这就足够了，对吧？如果有人传入“Monday”，那么我只需取前两个字母“MO”，然后在表中查找它。
And that would return zero. And I've saved some data. I didn't have to store all of Monday. Now, you know, I couldn't use one letter because if I did, then Tuesday and Thursday would both map to the same location. That's called a collision. Right.
那就会返回 0。而且我节省了一些数据。我不必存储整个“Monday”。现在，你知道，我不能使用一个字母，因为如果我这样做，那么“Tuesday”和“Thursday”都会映射到同一个位置。这叫做冲突。对。
And so there's ways to deal with that even. So it's not the end of the world. But, you know, I could store two letters and save a lot of data. And so hash tables, you know, there's a lot to it. You know, if you're really good at hash tables, hash tables are sort of the backbone of just about everything in computer science, especially distributed processing or, you know, web and stuff like that. So it would take a whole show, but in a nutshell, Lisp and the way Lisp works, the objects in Lisp are very hash friendly. And on top of that, Lisp can do a lot of object reuse.
所以即使有办法处理这个问题。所以这不是世界末日。但是，你知道，我可以存储两个字母并节省大量数据。所以哈希表，你知道，有很多学问。你知道，如果你非常擅长哈希表，哈希表可以说是计算机科学中几乎所有东西的骨干，特别是分布式处理，或者，你知道，网络之类的东西。所以这需要一整期节目，但简而言之，Lisp 以及 Lisp 的工作方式，Lisp 中的对象非常适合哈希。最重要的是，Lisp 可以进行大量的对象重用。
So it can implement hash tables very efficiently, very quickly. It can implement them without using a lot of memory. And this is really important for the applications, which we'll talk about later. So do you have any other strengths for LISP? So one thing that, well, I guess this is one of those, it could be a strength and could be a weakness, is that you can use LISPs to parse itself. So the difference between data and instructions in a C++, Java, Python program is very clear.
所以它可以非常高效、非常快速地实现哈希表。它可以在不使用大量内存的情况下实现它们。这对于我们稍后将讨论的应用程序非常重要。那么你对 LISP 还有其他优势吗？所以有一件事，嗯，我想这是其中之一，它既可以是优势也可以是劣势，那就是你可以使用 LISP 来解析它自己。所以 C++、Java、Python 程序中数据和指令之间的区别非常清晰。
It's very much here's my code and here's the data I'm storing. I'm assigning this data to this variable. And only in a few kind of edge cases where you might talk about function pointers or you know some kind of obscure things where your variable stores a pointer to code or code somewhere but that isn't the usual case it doesn't normally happen but in list you can have your your program is represented as one as these pairs so you can this there's very easy to intermix both the data and the program and that
它非常明确，这是我的代码，这是我存储的数据。我正在将此数据分配给此变量。只有在少数几种边缘情况下，你可能会谈论函数指针，或者，你知道，某种模糊的东西，你的变量存储了一个指向代码的指针，或者代码在某处，但这并不是通常的情况，它通常不会发生。但在 Lisp 中，你可以拥有你的程序，它被表示为这些对之一，所以你可以，这非常容易将数据和程序混合在一起，而这
means that you can manipulate the program so that's known as self-modification so when the code as it's running changes the code that's running and in lisp this is easy to do because the like i said there's no real distinction between data and the program and yeah that's a strength that gives you there's some really powerful techniques that you can do and that make really efficient code um it also happens to be something that can be very hard to understand um but it it's one of those with great power comes great responsibility. If you use it wisely, it can be very powerful. And if you use it poorly, it can cause problems.
意味着你可以操作程序，这就是所谓的自修改。所以当代码在运行时改变正在运行的代码时，在 Lisp 中这很容易做到，因为就像我说的，数据和程序之间没有真正的区别。是的，这是一个优势，它赋予了你一些你可以做的非常强大的技术，并且可以生成非常高效的代码。嗯，它也恰好是某种可能非常难以理解的东西。嗯，但它是那种“能力越大，责任越大”的东西。如果你明智地使用它，它会非常强大。如果你使用得不好，它可能会导致问题。
But Lisp is really good at doing that. Look at the roguelike, for example. So let's say you're making a simple roguelike game following the 15 steps and uh you know you make a sword uh and uh you have this sword class and you have some data like you have the great sword where the name is great and um it does like 10 damage and then you have like the awesome sword so you have some text file and the text file just has, you know, great sword, comma, 10, awesome sword, comma, 20, you know, light sword, comma, 30. And so, like, then you write some C program that looks at your text file and then says, okay, create, you know, create a great sword, create an awesome sword, and then put these in somewhere in memory so that I can fill my world full of great and awesome swords but
但 Lisp 在做这件事上真的很擅长。以 Roguelike 游戏为例。所以假设你正在按照 15 个步骤制作一个简单的 Roguelike 游戏，呃，你知道，你制作了一把剑，呃，你有这个剑类，并且你有一些数据，比如你有“巨剑”，名字是“Great”，嗯，它造成 10 点伤害，然后你有“极品剑”，所以你有一个文本文件，文本文件里只有，你知道，“Great sword, 10, Awesome sword, 20, Light sword, 30”。所以，就像，然后你编写一些 C 程序，它查看你的文本文件，然后说，好的，创建，你知道，创建一个巨剑，创建一个极品剑，然后把这些放在内存中的某个地方，这样我就可以用巨剑和极品剑填满我的世界，但是
what if i wanted a flaming sword and when you hit somebody with it um they caught on fire and there was all this code and stuff like that well you know that can't really go in the text file you know i mean you can't describe the flames yeah you can't describe the flames and the effect and the person catching on fire and what that means all that logic you can't just the flames. Yeah, you can't describe the flames and the effect and the person catching on fire and what that means, all that logic. You can't just put that in the text file. I mean, you'd have to put it in the C file and then know that, oh, a flaming sword has this, right? But with Lisp, your data and your code is the same thing. So in Lisp, you'd have in lisp you would have you know a pair and the pair the first element would
如果我想要一把火焰剑，当你用它击中某人时，嗯，他们会着火，并且有所有这些代码之类的东西，嗯，你知道，那真的不能放进文本文件里。你知道，我的意思是，你不能描述火焰。是的，你不能描述火焰和效果，以及人着火以及这意味着什么，所有这些逻辑。你不能只是……火焰。是的，你不能描述火焰和效果，以及人着火以及这意味着什么，所有这些逻辑。你不能只是把这些放进文本文件里。我的意思是，你必须把它放进 C 文件里，然后知道，哦，一把火焰剑有这个，对吧？但是使用 Lisp，你的数据和代码是同一回事。所以在 Lisp 中，你会有，在 Lisp 中，你会拥有，你知道，一个对，这个对的第一个元素会
be the name and the second element would be a pair which would have the you know damage and then you know the third element there could be an entire list program which is what happens when you hit someone with the sword and you don't have to worry about reading your data from the text file like you do in C and, like, you know, creating sort objects based on the data in the text file. You just load that Lisp file and it's done. So, yeah, you could do some awesome stuff with it. But, yeah, I mean, it makes it very difficult to debug and things like that. So, yeah. It's kind of a wild thing that you have at your fingertips.
是名字，第二个元素会是一个对，它会包含，你知道，伤害，然后，你知道，第三个元素可以是一个完整的 Lisp 程序，这就是当你用剑击中某人时发生的事情。你不需要像在 C 中那样担心从文本文件中读取数据，并且，你知道，根据文本文件中的数据创建剑对象。你只需加载那个 Lisp 文件，它就完成了。所以，是的，你可以用它做一些很棒的事情。但是，是的，我的意思是，它使得调试变得非常困难，诸如此类。所以，是的。这是一种你触手可及的狂野东西。
So with all of the, these things are nice features. Everything's a pair. And the language provides some abstraction. So I guess we should say that even though everything under the hood is a pair, the languages allow you to not have to literally, if you want to make a list, have a pair where the second element is another pair and the second element is another pair.
所以，所有这些都是不错的功能。一切都是一个对。并且该语言提供了一些抽象。所以我想我们应该说，即使底层的一切都是一个对，这些语言也允许你不需要字面上地，如果你想创建一个列表，拥有一个第二个元素是另一个对，而第二个元素又是另一个对的对。
They give you the power to just make one long list and do that pairing for you. Yeah, that's a good point. So yeah, I was just thinking about that because one of the weaknesses though, even with that that, Lisp tends to have a ton of parentheses and parentheses are what are used to kind of wrap each pair. Yeah. I mean, it's, you know, they've done a lot to make it less painful. So as Patrick mentioned, if you have 10 items, you can just put a single parentheses around them and lisp under
它们赋予你权力，只需创建一个长列表，并为你完成那种配对。是的，这是一个很好的观点。所以是的，我刚才在想那个，因为其中一个弱点是，即使有那个，Lisp 往往有大量的括号，而括号是用来包裹每个对的东西。是的。我的意思是，你知道，他们做了很多工作来让它不那么痛苦。所以正如 Patrick 提到的，如果你有 10 个项目，你可以只在它们周围放一个括号，而 Lisp 在
the hood knows that it's like a bunch of pairs that are all chained together but the fact is yeah i mean there's just you're dealing with pairs and and uh as you might imagine there's as a lot of there's a lot of data a lot of variables you might have in your code, you're going to have a ton of parentheses. That's kind of endemic of Lisp programs. So fortunately, if you use Emacs, it'll match up. Or actually, I guess most modern, or not even modern, most editors will do this for you. But it'll help you match up the parentheses. But yeah, it still can make things
底层知道它就像一堆链在一起的对。但事实是，是的，我的意思是，你只是在处理对，而且，呃，正如你可能想象的那样，有很多，有很多数据，很多变量你可能在你的代码中拥有，你会有大量的括号。这有点像 Lisp 程序的特有现象。所以幸运的是，如果你使用 Emacs，它会匹配它们。或者实际上，我想大多数现代的，或者甚至不是现代的，大多数编辑器都会为你做这件事。但它会帮助你匹配括号。但是的，它仍然会让事情
a little cumbersome yeah it's not really a weakness but it is something when people look at lisp code some languages you don't exactly know at first like c++ and java sometimes you have to kind of look at certain lines of code to kind of understand what it is when you look at lisp code it's really easy to tell because you just look for all the parentheses. Yeah, I mean, think about this. As we mentioned, again, everything's a pair. So if you want to add two numbers, what you really want, you want a pair of a plus sign and a pair of a 2 and a 3 underneath it. So you have now with C Lisp and more advanced Lisp,
变得有点繁琐。是的，这并不是真正的弱点，但当人们看 Lisp 代码时，这确实是一件事。有些语言，你起初并不完全知道，比如 C++ 和 Java，有时你必须查看某些代码行才能理解它是什么。当你查看 Lisp 代码时，这真的很容易分辨，因为你只需寻找所有的括号。是的，我的意思是，想想这个。正如我们提到的，再次强调，一切都是一个对。所以如果你想把两个数字相加，你真正想要的是，你想要一个加号的对，以及它下面一个 2 和 3 的对。所以你现在有了 C Lisp 和更高级的 Lisp，
you can take away the parentheses around the 2 and the 3. But you're going to have a parentheses and away the parentheses around the 2 and the 3. But you're going to have a parentheses and then the plus sign and then 2 and 3. That's another thing about Lisp is that everything is in prefix notation. So if you want to do 2 plus 3, you actually want to do plus 2, 3. And so because it's in prefix, let's say you wanted to do 2 plus 3 minus 4. It would actually be plus minus 2, 3, 4. So now that doesn't make any sense, right?
你可以去掉 2 和 3 周围的括号。但你会有一个括号，去掉 2 和 3 周围的括号。但你会有一个括号，然后是加号，然后是 2 和 3。关于 Lisp 的另一件事是，一切都是前缀表示法。所以如果你想做 2 加 3，你实际上想做“加 2 3”。所以因为它是前缀的，假设你想做 2 加 3 减 4。它实际上会是“加 减 2 3 4”。所以现在这没有任何意义，对吧？
Because the order of operations, you don't really know. Prefix notation doesn't really give you order of operations. So to deal with all that that you specify the order explicitly. So to do 2 plus 3 minus 4 you'd actually do open parentheses open parentheses minus sign or yeah minus sign open parentheses plus sign 2 3 close parentheses 4 close parentheses. So just to do something that simple you already needed four parentheses like two opening and two closing. So it can get pretty cumbersome. But one of the other, you know, weaknesses of Lisp beyond just the syntax is that it doesn't have direct memory access and doesn't really have much in the way of hardware access. So people have written extensions, but for the most part, it's not really designed to fit the model of a computer. And this is one of the things that
因为运算顺序，你真的不知道。前缀表示法并没有真正给你运算顺序。所以为了处理所有这些，你明确指定顺序。所以要做 2 加 3 减 4，你实际上会做“左括号 左括号 减号 或 是的 减号 左括号 加号 2 3 右括号 4 右括号”。所以仅仅为了做那么简单的事情，你已经需要四个括号，比如两个左括号和两个右括号。所以它可能会变得相当繁琐。但 Lisp 的另一个弱点，除了语法之外，就是它没有直接的内存访问，也没有太多的硬件访问方式。所以人们编写了扩展，但在大多数情况下，它并不是真正设计用来适应计算机模型的。而这是其中之一
really hurt Lisp. And that's what inspired people to make the Lisp machines that they did 20, 30 years ago. Yeah. And that's really fundamental, being able to manipulate specific memory locations, because that's, you know, for people who have never done it before, it may not be obvious, but that's how at the lowest level all the drivers work. So the things that control hardware all come down to basically putting certain values at certain memory locations. And doing that causes something to happen electrically on that peripheral device and that's how device drivers are written and so if you don't have the ability to control exactly what the contents of a certain memory location are then you're not going to be able to control that device and you can't write device drivers and that's what a lot of low-level code is working with those kinds of things yeah i mean's what a lot of low-level code is working with, those kinds of things.
真正伤害了 Lisp 的事情。而这正是激励人们在 20、30 年前制造他们所制造的 Lisp 机器的原因。是的。而且这非常基础，能够操作特定的内存位置，因为那是，你知道，对于从来没做过的人来说，这可能不明显，但这就是在最低级别上所有驱动程序工作的方式。所以控制硬件的东西归根结底基本上是在特定的内存位置放置特定的值。而这样做会导致该外围设备上发生电学上的事情，这就是设备驱动程序的编写方式。所以如果你没有能力控制特定内存位置的内容到底是什么，那么你就无法控制该设备，你也就无法编写设备驱动程序，而这就是许多底层代码正在处理的东西，那些类型的东西。是的，我的意思是，这就是许多底层代码正在处理的东西，那些类型的东西。
Yeah, I mean, you know, a lot of people are probably too young. A lot of people listening to the show are too young to have serial mouse. But when I started learning about computers, I had a serial mouse. And what that was was the plug for the mouse had, how much does a serial port have? Like eight pins, I think? Nine. Or 16? Nine. Nine pins? Yeah. Really, nine Like 8 pins, I think? Or 9 pins?
是的，我的意思是，你知道，很多人可能太年轻了。听这个节目的很多人太年轻了，没用过串行鼠标。但当我开始学习计算机时，我有一个串行鼠标。那是什么，鼠标的插头有，串行端口有多少？我想有八个引脚？九个。或者 16 个？九个。九个引脚？是的。真的，九个？像 8 个引脚，我想？或者 9 个引脚？
Really? 9? Or a mouse? Or just a regular serial port? No, this isn't a PS2. This is like an old serial mouse. I think it was even before my time. But then that was 9 pins. Okay. So just think of that.
真的？9 个？或者鼠标？或者只是一个普通的串行端口？不，这不是 PS2。这就像一个旧的串行鼠标。我想它甚至在我那个时代之前。但那是 9 个引脚。好的。所以只需想想那个。
It has 9 pins and it naturally fits an array. You know, if you want the eighth pin, then you call array index seven, right? So, I mean, the way that computers are architected and built, you know, the way memory is laid out, all of these things sort of fit the linear, you know, C model. And, you know, back when it was really important, when speed was really important before computers got as fast as they were, and when, you know, storage is really important for hard drives got as cheap as they are now. The languages like C just completely dominated. And only now are people starting to leverage more like productivity focused languages like Python. But Lisp was
它有 9 个引脚，它自然适合一个数组。你知道，如果你想要第八个引脚，那么你调用数组索引 7，对吧？所以，我的意思是，计算机架构和构建的方式，你知道，内存布局的方式，所有这些东西都某种程度上适合线性的，你知道，C 模型。而且，你知道，在它非常重要的时候，在计算机变得像现在这么快之前，速度非常重要，而且当，你知道，存储对于硬盘驱动器变得像现在这么便宜非常重要时。像 C 这样的语言就完全占据了主导地位。直到现在，人们才开始利用更多像 Python 这样以生产力为中心的语言。但 Lisp 是
really sort of only, you know, useful to academics at the time when it was most popular. So you already kind of mentioned that Lisp is used a lot in the artificial intelligence community. What kinds of things do you guys use it for yeah so um so this was very was used a lot in planning and so let me explain a little bit of what planning is planning is basically uh searching through like a particular space and figuring out sort of what are the optimal actions to take so for example uh path planning is you know let's say you have again let's say you're making a roguelike game and you have this grid world uh you know sort of like a where the whole world is just a grid of numbers you're at coordinate x you're at you're at you know coordinate three comma five and you take a step to the left now
真的某种程度上只是，你知道，在它最流行的时候对学术界有用。所以你已经提到 Lisp 在人工智能社区中被大量使用。你们用它来做什么？是的，所以，嗯，所以这在规划中被大量使用，所以让我解释一下规划是什么。规划基本上是，呃，搜索一个特定的空间，并弄清楚，你知道，采取什么最优行动。例如，呃，路径规划是，你知道，假设你有，再次假设你正在制作一个 Roguelike 游戏，并且你有一个网格世界，呃，你知道，有点像一个整个世界只是一个数字网格的地方。你在坐标 x，你在，你在，你知道，坐标 3 逗号 5，然后你向左走一步，现在
you're at coordinate four comma five it's very discreet right and so you know, coordinate 3, 5, and then you take a step to the left. Now you're at coordinate 4, 5. It's very discreet, right? And so, you know, you want to navigate through some maze in this grid world. What you want to do is to plan. You want to sort of try all the possible moves you can make and then see where you are. Are you closer to the goal? Are you further away from the goal? Like what's the state of the world after after these different actions i could take so again going back to list strengths right
你在坐标 4 逗号 5，它非常离散，对吧？所以你知道，坐标 3, 5，然后你向左走一步。现在你在坐标 4, 5。它非常离散，对吧？所以，你知道，你想在这个网格世界中导航穿过某个迷宫。你想做的是规划。你想某种程度上尝试所有你能做的可能的移动，然后看看你在哪里。你离目标更近了吗？你离目标更远了吗？在这些我能采取的不同行动之后，世界的状态是什么？所以再次回到 Lisp 的优势，对吧？
let's you can create a hash table where the key is the entire world um the state of the world as it is so so in this grid world the key might be just your position and the value would be you know how close you are to the goal or maybe even just you want the hash table to store as a key the state of the world and as a value whether you've seen this state or not so if i take a step to the left that's a new state so i'll put that in the hash table and then let's say i try take a step to the left, that's a new state. So I'll put that in the hash table. And then let's say I try taking a step to the right. Well, that puts me in the same state I started at. So I go to my hash table.
让你可以创建一个哈希表，其中键是整个世界，嗯，世界的状态，正如它所是的那样。所以，在这个网格世界中，键可能只是你的位置，而值将是，你知道，你离目标有多近，或者也许甚至只是你想要哈希表存储作为键的世界状态，以及作为值的你是否见过这个状态。所以如果我向左走一步，那是一个新状态，所以我把它放进哈希表中，然后假设我尝试，向左走一步，那是一个新状态。所以我把它放进哈希表中。然后假设我尝试向右走一步。嗯，那把我带回了我开始时的同一个状态。所以我去我的哈希表。
I say, hey, here's some new world I discovered. This is the world where I'm at coordinate 4, 5. And the hash table says, no, you've already been here before. Like, don't bother trying to go further like you've already tried all the actions when you're at four comma five and so doing this will keep you from just going left right left right left right you know so eventually you'll explore all of the possible game states um all the possible world states until you get to the state where you're at the goal um now to take it to the next level,
我说，嘿，这是我发现的一些新世界。这是我处于坐标 4, 5 的世界。而哈希表说，不，你以前来过这里。就像，别费心尝试走得更远，因为当你处于 4 逗号 5 时，你已经尝试了所有行动。所以这样做会阻止你只是左、右、左、右、左、右，你知道，所以最终你会探索所有可能的游戏状态，嗯，所有可能的世界状态，直到你到达你处于目标的状态。嗯，现在将其提升到下一个级别，
the hash table could not only say whether you've been at that state before, but it could say how you got there. So, you know, once you get to the goal, you can say, okay, this state of the world that I visited or that I'm at now, how did I get here? Check the hash table. The hash table will say, oh, you got here
哈希表不仅可以说明你以前是否处于该状态，而且它可以说明你是如何到达那里的。所以，你知道，一旦你到达目标，你可以说，好的，我访问过的或者我现在所处的这个世界状态，我是怎么到这里的？检查哈希表。哈希表会说，哦，你到这里是
by making a move to the right so you could do the opposite backtrack right make a move to the left and say this state of the world how did I get here it could say oh you got here by moving down so on and so forth so this is planning and to do effective planning you need good heuristics which that's just simple algebra so you can do heuristics in any language. But you need an awesome hash table, and Lisp definitely gives you that. So it's very useful for planning. Expert systems is also good at this.
通过向右移动，所以你可以做相反的回溯，对吧？向左移动，并说这个世界状态，我是怎么到这里的？它可能会说，哦，你是通过向下移动到这里的，以此类推。所以这就是规划，要进行有效的规划，你需要好的启发式方法，这只是简单的代数，所以你可以在任何语言中进行启发式方法。但你需要一个很棒的哈希表，而 Lisp 绝对给了你那个。所以它对于规划非常有用。专家系统也擅长这个。
This is kind of a buzzword. Expert systems is basically planning, but instead of planning over something very discreet like as we mentioned planning through a grid world or something like that in the case of expert systems you're planning over rules so this is similar to prologue actually this is almost exactly prologue but at a lower level yeah so you know in the case of prologue it's this really high level abstract language where you're specifying these rules in the case of lisp sort of you would be creating the prologue interpreter essentially in lisp but you could also do other low level things like you
这有点像一个流行语。专家系统基本上是规划，但不是在像我们提到的通过网格世界之类的非常离散的东西上进行规划，在专家系统的情况下，你是在规则上进行规划。所以这实际上类似于 Prolog，这几乎完全是 Prolog，但在更低的级别上。是的，所以你知道，在 Prolog 的情况下，它是一种非常高级的抽象语言，你在其中指定这些规则。在 Lisp 的情况下，某种程度上，你基本上是在 Lisp 中创建 Prolog 解释器，但你也可以做其他底层的事情，比如你
could have rules that were mathematically based you do things like that. And so a mathematically based rule system which parsed natural language, it basically tokenized the languages, the natural, tokenized the text into syllables. And then based on the syllables, tried to get an understanding for the language, like where the noun is in the sentence, where the verb is. There's a system that did this called SHRDLU, S-H-R-D-L-U, and it really made Lisp famous. So what this guy did, he was able to scan an entire encyclopedia, and then for each sentence he was able to figure out where the noun,
可以拥有基于数学的规则，你做类似的事情。所以一个基于数学的规则系统，它解析自然语言，它基本上将语言标记化，自然，将文本标记化为音节。然后基于音节，尝试对语言获得一种理解，比如名词在句子中的位置，动词在哪里。有一个系统做了这个，叫做 SHRDLU，S-H-R-D-L-U，它真的让 Lisp 出名了。所以这个家伙做了什么，他能够扫描整本百科全书，然后对于每个句子，他能够弄清楚名词在哪里，
the verb, the object of the preposition, all the different parts of speech for that sentence. And then he created a hash table for each sentence where the key was the, I believe the key was the verb and the value was the noun, something like that. But basically, because he scanned the entire encyclopedia, you could ask it questions like, how many toes or how many legs does a zebra have? And it actually could tell you answers in English. So you would literally type in how many legs does a zebra have? And it would answer you a zebra has four legs in English. And this, this blew people's mind, right? When this program came out, people thought, okay, you you know we're going to get a human robot in the next five years now this program came out like in the 60s right uh or maybe not that late maybe like the
动词、介词宾语，那个句子的所有不同词性。然后他为每个句子创建了一个哈希表，其中键是，我相信键是动词，值是名词，类似那样。但基本上，因为他扫描了整本百科全书，你可以问它问题，比如，斑马有多少脚趾或有多少条腿？它实际上可以用英语告诉你答案。所以你字面上会输入“斑马有多少条腿？”它会用英语回答你“斑马有四条腿”。而这，这让人们大吃一惊，对吧？当这个程序出来时，人们认为，好的，你知道，我们将在未来五年内得到一个人形机器人。现在这个程序是在 60 年代出来的，对吧？呃，或者也许没那么晚，也许像
70s but i mean you know it shocked like it rocked the ai community and uh and it was done by lisp and it really made lisp uh very popular at the time another thing that people use list for and you you talked about a little before but uh emacs yeah you mentioned that it'll help you do the parentheses matching which a lot of editors will do but emacs um uses a version of lisp as a way to do its extending the emacs editor so the emacs is one of the uh i don't even want to say anything because it'll just start a flame war but uh emacs is one of the editors that is popular on the linux platform and i'll say it is a emacs is the best editor um for the linux platform and also all right the only thing that might be better is xemax i'm not going to say anything because i i want to not have my email inbox completely filled with
70 年代，但我的意思是，你知道，它震惊了，它震撼了 AI 社区，而且它是用 Lisp 完成的，它真的让 Lisp 在当时非常流行。人们使用 Lisp 的另一件事，你之前也谈到了一点，但，呃，Emacs。是的，你提到它会帮助你做括号匹配，很多编辑器都会这样做，但 Emacs，嗯，使用 Lisp 的一个版本作为一种扩展 Emacs 编辑器的方法。所以 Emacs 是，呃，我甚至不想说什么，因为它只会引发一场口水战，但，呃，Emacs 是在 Linux 平台上流行的编辑器之一，我会说它是 Emacs 是最好的编辑器，呃，对于 Linux 平台，而且也，好的，唯一可能更好的东西是 XEmacs。我什么都不会说，因为我不想让我的电子邮件收件箱完全被
people writing in about this yeah i have a feeling the guy who sits at the stand-up desk will be kicking my ass tomorrow oh and he has a very strong leg because he's been standing on it all day he's standing the whole time well no he'll rest on the chair first the leaning chair yeah for a few minutes that's right and then he'll and then he'll rest on the chair first, the leaning chair for a few minutes. That's right. And then he'll kick me down. So Emacs allows you the option to add functionality and increase its abilities by writing in a form of Lisp in one of the Lisp dialects. Right.
写信来讨论这个的人填满。是的，我有种感觉，那个坐在站立式办公桌前的人明天会踢我的屁股。哦，而且他有一条非常有力的腿，因为他整天都站在上面。他一直站着。嗯，不，他会先靠在椅子上，那个倾斜的椅子，嗯，几分钟。那是对的，然后他会，然后他会先靠在椅子上，那个倾斜的椅子，几分钟。那是对的。然后他会把我踢倒。所以 Emacs 允许你选择添加功能，并通过用 Lisp 的一种形式，用 Lisp 的方言之一编写来增加它的能力。对。
And that's a very popular use of the Lisp language. Yeah, definitely. Also, I guess it's the what's the ita stand for is like international traffic it stands for but google now owns them but they were kind of yeah like the big back-end infrastructure servers for they're like all of the major internet travel websites like orbit traveloc, that went and queried a system for tickets, information, flight paths, times, on-time percentages, those kinds of things, these people, like, tracked all of that data. They were, like, the people who all these websites used to get that information from.
而那是 Lisp 语言的一种非常流行的用途。是的，绝对。此外，我想它是，ITA 代表什么，是像国际交通，它代表，但谷歌现在拥有他们，但他们某种程度上是，是的，就像大型后端基础设施服务器，对于，他们就像所有主要的互联网旅游网站，比如 Orbitz、Travelocity，那些去查询系统获取票务、信息、飞行路径、时间、准点率之类的东西，这些人，就像，追踪了所有那些数据。他们就像，所有这些网站用来获取该信息的人。
And all of their software was written in Lisp. Yeah, that's right. So I think, you know, they've probably been around for a long time. Yes. And they, you know, probably when they were around, other languages like Python and things like that probably weren't that popular or maybe even didn't exist. And so they were, you know, had the foresight to jump on a productivity based you know productivity focused language like lists and so it's carried them all the way to today so definitely lists have been using in enterprise solutions another more academic
而他们所有的软件都是用 Lisp 编写的。是的，那是对的。所以我认为，你知道，他们可能已经存在很长时间了。是的。而且他们，你知道，可能当他们存在时，其他语言比如 Python 之类的可能并不那么流行，或者甚至不存在。所以他们，你知道，有远见去跳上一门以生产力为基础的，你知道，以生产力为中心的语言，比如 Lisp，所以它一直支撑他们到今天。所以绝对，Lisp 一直被用于企业解决方案。另一个更学术的
application of lists that was very popular again at the time was maxima which is a computer algebra system so you know algebra really is a planning problem you know especially at a higher level like you think about it you you have an equation let's say you have uh like let's say a simple equation like you have uh you know four divided by two plus three and you just want to know the answer to that so you know that's that. So you have to do planning. In this case, you only have one thing you can do, which is a division because of order of operations. So you divide the 4 by the 2.
当时非常流行的一个Lisp应用是Maxima，它是一个计算机代数系统。你知道，代数实际上是一个规划问题，特别是在更高层次上。比如你考虑一下，你有一个方程，比方说一个简单的方程，像4除以2加3，你只想知道答案。所以你知道就是这样。你必须进行规划。在这种情况下，你只有一件事可以做，那就是除法，因为有运算顺序。所以你用4除以2。
That's your one action. Now you're into a new state where you have 2 plus 3. Then you take another action where you combine those and you get 5. But as you get to more advanced things, especially like integrals where there's many different rules you can use or derivatives or you get to differential equations where there's 10 if not 15 or 20 different ways you can solve a particular ODE, particular differential equation. So this thing does planning and says all right again let's here's the state of the world it's this differential equation let's put it in a hash table and then let's start trying different rules different ODE different
这是你的第一个动作。现在你进入了一个新状态，剩下2加3。然后你采取另一个动作，将它们合并，得到5。但当你处理更高级的问题时，特别是像积分，有许多不同的规则可以使用，或者导数，或者当你处理微分方程时，有10个甚至15或20种不同的方法可以解决特定的常微分方程（ODE）。所以这个系统会进行规划，并说：好吧，这是当前的世界状态，即这个微分方程，让我们把它放入哈希表中，然后开始尝试不同的规则，不同的ODE，不同的
differential equation solvers and it can it can sort of try these rules, and by enacting these rules on the equation, it creates a new equation. And that's a new entry in the hash table. And the hope is eventually it can reduce some really complex differential equation into something much simpler. Or it can reduce some integral using some trig identity into something much simpler. So Maxima used planning to solve many computer algebra problems. All right, well, I think that wraps it up. Yeah, so yeah, the uses were pretty cool. The Maxima computer algebra system, the ITA software, Emacs, AI,
微分方程求解器。它可以尝试这些规则，通过在方程上应用这些规则，它会创建一个新的方程。这就是哈希表中的一个新条目。希望最终它能将一些非常复杂的微分方程简化为更简单的形式。或者它可以使用某些三角恒等式将某个积分简化为更简单的形式。所以Maxima使用规划来解决许多计算机代数问题。好了，我想这就总结到这里。是的，这些用途非常酷。Maxima计算机代数系统、ITA软件、Emacs、AI，
this has been used for some pretty awesome things. And it's also very interesting to learn so uh definitely take a look at it and uh stay tuned yeah i've said that before said this before but uh lisp is one of those languages where learning it even if you don't use it in your day-to-day job or don't ever become super amazingly proficient at it uh it's one of those things that'll help you become a better programmer. Yeah, definitely. So, you know, if a couple of people have been adding us on Google+, that's awesome. Definitely add us.
它已经被用于一些非常棒的事情。而且学习它也非常有趣，所以一定要看一看，敬请关注。是的，我以前说过，但我还是要再说一遍，Lisp是那种即使你不在日常工作中用到它，或者永远无法达到精通程度，它也能帮助你成为一名更好的程序员的语言之一。是的，绝对是。所以，如果有一些人一直在Google+上添加我们，那太棒了。一定要添加我们。
We actually invited anyone I knew from my programming throwdown circle, we invited to the Hangout. So definitely, you know, can take some of your questions and your feedback directly when we do the shows and things like that, which would be awesome. So... Try that out, see how that goes.
我们实际上邀请了我在Programming Throwdown圈子里认识的任何人参加Hangout。所以，当我们做节目时，绝对可以直接听取你们的问题和反馈，这会很棒。所以……试试看，看看效果如何。
Yeah, yeah. But shoot us an email. So add my name on plus is jgmath2000 at gmail.com. And I think you're P. Wheeler, right? Patrick LW. Oh, sorry. Patrick LW at gmail.com is Patrick.
是的，是的。但给我们发封邮件吧。在Google+上添加我的名字是jgmath2000@gmail.com。我想你是P. Wheeler，对吧？Patrick LW。哦，抱歉。Patrick LW@gmail.com是Patrick。
Shoot us an email before you add us to your circles so that we know that you're in Programming Throwdown and we know that you're not some spam bot or something like that although you know spam really has been brought to quite a minimum on g plus i haven't seen too much of it but yeah just in case shoot us an email let us know uh you know give us some love yeah for all of you who have added me i know some people have and i haven't added you back i'm working out a system i'm trying to keep my stream with people that like I'm really trying to pay attention to and I still haven't figured out how to add people and then not you know have
在把我们加入你的圈子之前给我们发封邮件，这样我们就知道你是Programming Throwdown的听众，而不是什么垃圾邮件机器人之类的。虽然垃圾邮件在G+上已经减少到最低限度了，我没怎么见过，但以防万一，还是发封邮件告诉我们一声，给我们一点爱。是的，对于所有添加了我的人，我知道有些人添加了我，但我还没回加。我正在制定一个系统，试图让我的信息流里都是我真正想关注的人，但我还没弄清楚如何添加别人而不让
them flood out my normal stream but I have been looking at what you write on my incoming stream so don't feel like uh that I'm just I'm being mean to you yeah definitely I'm gonna keep uh inviting anyone in my programming throwdown circle to the hangout before you record um so if you have any feedback you want to add or if you have any questions or if you have a language we'll do a we'll do an impromptu language i'll throw down the gauntlet right now and say that if someone has the right timing to jump into our hangout while we're recording the podcast we will do whatever language they want well i will i will make it that if they are willing to come on the podcast if we don't know anything about it and and do at least part of this spiel of it yeah that's
他们淹没我的正常信息流。但我一直在看你们在我的收件流中写的内容，所以不要觉得我在对你们刻薄。是的，我绝对会继续邀请Programming Throwdown圈子里的任何人参加录制前的Hangout。所以如果你有任何想添加的反馈，或者有任何问题，或者有某种语言，我们会做一个即兴的语言节目。我现在就下战书，如果有人有合适的时间跳进我们的Hangout，在我们录制播客时，我们会做他们想要的任何语言。好吧，我会设定一个条件，如果他们愿意上播客，即使我们对它一无所知，并且至少完成这部分介绍，那
true we we need somehow if someone comes in and says oh i want you to do Motorola assembly at buy, you know, I mean, then we can't, we're kind of stuck. Right. Um, or I want you to do M 68 K you know, Donkey Kong assembly or something, but, but, um, you know, yeah, you definitely have to be willing to help out, help us out. Cause we're going to be floundering a little bit, but I will throw down the gauntlet now and say, we'll do any language someone wants. If they jump in the hang us. Jason might be doing it by himself. But yeah, shoot us an email, let us know so that we know who you are. And yes, that would be awesome. And definitely check out the blog, programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com. And our email address is programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. Yeah, that's right. So I guess until two weeks from now, have a good one, stay safe, and learn you some Lisp for great good.
确实，如果有人进来并说：哦，我想要你们做摩托罗拉汇编，那我们就被难住了。或者我想要你们做M68K，你知道，大金刚汇编之类的。但是，你绝对必须愿意提供帮助。因为我们会有点手忙脚乱，但我现在下战书，说我们会做任何人想要的任何语言。如果他们跳进Hangout的话。Jason可能会独自完成。但是的，给我们发封邮件，让我们知道你是谁。那会很棒。一定要看看博客，programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com。我们的电子邮件地址是programmingthrowdown@gmail.com。是的，没错。所以我想直到两周后，祝大家一切顺利，保持安全，学习一些Lisp，为了伟大的进步。
All right, take care. See you. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，保重。再见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。